♪ ♪
>> Chris: CONTINUE THIS
WEEKEND AS CONGRESSIONAL
DEMOCRATS IN THE WHITE HOUSE TRY
TO STRIKE A DEAL TO PROVIDE MORE
MONEY FOR A PROGRAM MEANT HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES SHUT DOWN BY
THE CORONAVIRUS.
EARLIER, I TALKED WITH THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
NANCY PELOSI, ABOUT THAT AND
MORE.
>> Chris: SPEAKER PELOSI, GOOD
TO TALK TO YOU AGAIN.
THE $350 BILLION FUND TO PROVIDE
LOANS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES IS
RUN OUT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS YOU AND
OTHER DEMOCRATS ARE BLOCKING A
DEAL TO PROVIDE ANOTHER
250 BILLION.
HERE HE IS ON THAT.
>> NANCY PELOSI, SHE’S AWAY ON
VACATION OR SOMETHING AND SHE’S
COME BACK.
SHE NEEDS TO COME BACK AND GET
THIS DONE.
I DON’T KNOW WHY SHE’S NOT
COMING BACK.
THE FACT IS, SHE’S NOT DOING HER
JOB.
>> Chris: THE PRESIDENT SAYS
HE NOW SUPPORTS YOUR CALL FOR
MORE MONEY FOR HOSPITALS, BUT
YOU’RE ALSO CALLING FOR MORE
MONEY FOR FIRST RESPONDERS, FOR
FOOD ASSISTANCE, STATES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
HOW LONG ARE YOU PREPARED TO
HOLD OUT, SPEAKER?
>> Speaker Pelosi: WELL, FIRST
OF ALL, I SUPPORT THE CARES ACT.
WE WERE VERY PLEASED TO BE ABLE
TO TURN IT FROM A CORPORATE
TRICKLE-DOWN BILL TO A
WORKERS-FIRST BUBBLE UP AND
SUPPORT THAT PPP AND PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM IN THERE.
AND SO, AS THEY HAVE COMMITTED,
THE MONEY THAT IS THERE, WE WANT
TO ADD MORE MONEY THERE.
IT IS VERY URGENT THOUGH THAT WE
SUPPORT OUR POLICE AND FIRE, OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS, OUR NURSES,
OUR TEACHERS.
AND THAT’S WHAT THE STATE AND
LOCAL IS ABOUT.
MEETING THE NEEDS OF THE
CORONAVIRUS AND EVERYTHING THAT
WE’RE DOING IS ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS.
UNDERSTAND THAT.
WE’RE NOT GOING TO FIELD AND ANY
OTHER THING.
AND ALSO TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO THE
PROGRAM.
I’M VERY PLEASED AT THE PROGRESS
THAT IS BEING MADE.
WE’VE WORKED IN A VERY
BIPARTISAN WAY ALL ALONG.
WE CONTINUE TO DO SO.
WE ALL PAY TRIBUTE TO OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES, WHICH ARE THE
OPTIMISM AND ENTREPRENEURIAL
SPIRIT OF AMERICA AND WE DON’T
WANT THERE TO BE ANY DOUBT THAT
IF THEY ARE PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROGRAM THAT THEY WILL BE FUNDED
AND IF THEY MEET THE STANDARDS
OF THE PROGRAM THAT THE LOANS
WILL BE FORGIVEN.
>> Chris: SO IS THERE GOING TO
BE A DEAL, AND IF SO, HOW SOON?
YOU KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE
RUNNING OUT OF MONEY AND ARE
HANGING ON BY THEIR FINGERNAILS.
>> Speaker Pelosi: YES.
AND WE WANT ALL OF THEM TO GET
WHAT THEY’RE ENTITLED TO UNDER
THE WALL AND EVEN MORE -- SOME
OF THE SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE
OTHER REQUESTS IN TERMS OF THE
ADDITIONAL LOAN PROGRAMS IN
ADDITION TO ITS GRANT PROGRAM
AND THAT’S PART OF OUR REQUEST
AS WELL.
THE MONEY HAS NOT BEEN
DISTRIBUTED, ALTHOUGH IT’S ALL
BEEN COMMITTED, AND THAT MEANS
THERE’S NO MORE MONEY.
THEY WILL HAVE MORE MONEY AS
SOON AS WE COME TO AGREEMENT,
WHICH WILL BE SOON AND I THINK
PEOPLE WILL BE VERY PLEASED.
SMALL BUSINESSES WILL STRIVE IN
A COMMUNITY WHERE AGAIN, HEALTH
IS ESSENTIAL TO THEM OPEN UP AND
THEY HAVE TO OPEN UP -- IT’S ONE
THING TO SAVE THE DAY.
IT’S ANOTHER THING TO HAVE
CUSTOMERS AT THE END OF THE DAY.
>> Chris: THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED A PLAN THIS WEEK TO
REOPEN THE COUNTRY AND YOU
IMMEDIATELY CRITICIZED IT.
I WANT TO PUT UP WHAT YOU SAID.
"THE WHITE HOUSE IS VAGUE AND
INCONSISTENT DOCUMENT DOES
NOTHING TO MAKE UP FOR THE
PRESIDENT’S FAILURE TO LISTEN TO
THE SCIENTISTS AND PRODUCE
AND DISTRIBUTE NATIONAL RAPID
TESTING.
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI ENDORSED THE
PLAN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF THESE THINGS ARE DONE
CORRECTLY, AND I BELIEVE THEY
CAN, WE WILL HAVE AND THERE WILL
BE ENOUGH TESTS TO ALLOW US TO
TAKE THIS COUNTRY SAFETY TO
PHASE ONE.
>> Chris: DON’T YOU BELIEVE
DR. FAUCI?
>> Speaker Pelosi: HE SAYS IF
THIS IS DONE PROPERLY.
WELL, IT HASN’T BEEN DONE IN
MARCH 4TH WE PASSED OUR FIRST
BILL, BIPARTISAN, TESTING,
TESTING, TESTING.
IT’S OVER SIX WEEKS AND IT
HASN’T BEEN DONE.
SO HE SAYING IF IT HAS BEEN DONE
PROPERLY.
WE ARE ALREADY VERY LATE ON
THAT.
IT HAS TO BE TESTING, TRACING,
CONTACT TRACING.
IT IS TO BE TREATMENT AND THERE
HAS TO BE QUARANTINE.
IT’S PART OF SOMETHING BIGGER AS
WELL TO BE DONE PROPERLY.
BUT WE ARE WAY LATE ON IT AND
THAT IS -- THE PRESIDENT GETS AN
F, A FAILURE ON THE TESTING.
DR. FAUCI IS RIGHT, IF IT IS
DONE PROPERLY.
IT HASN’T BEEN.
AND THAT I THINK PUTS IT IN THE
IF IT’S DONE, AN ADMISSION THAT
IT HASN’T BEEN DONE.
>> Chris: YOU ARE AS YOU ARE
RIGHT NOW HAVE BEEN VERY
CRITICAL OF PRESIDENT TRUMP,
ESPECIALLY FOR WHAT YOU SAY IS
THE TIME THAT HE LOST INITIALLY
IN JANUARY AND FEBRUARY IN
RESPONDING TO THE VIRUS, BUT I
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT ON
FEBRUARY 24TH YOU WENT ON A
WALKING TOUR OF CHINATOWN TO TRY
TO PROMOTE TOURISM THERE AND
HEAR SOME OF WHAT YOU HAD TO SAY
SAY.
>> THAT’S WHAT WE’RE TRYING TO
DO TODAY, IS SAY EVERYTHING IS
FINE HERE.
COME, BECAUSE PRECAUTIONS HAVE
BEEN TAKEN.
WE THINK IT’S VERY SAFE TO BE IN
CHINATOWN AT HOPE THAT OTHERS
WILL COME.
>> Chris: IF THE PRESIDENT
UNDERPLAYED THE THREAT IN THE
EARLY DAYS OF MY SPEAKER PELOSI,
DIDN’T YOU AS WELL?
>> Speaker Pelosi: NO.
AT WHAT WE WERE TRYING TO DO’S
AND THE DISCRIMINATION, THE
STATEMENT THAT WAS GOING OUT
AGAINST THE ASIAN-AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AND IN FACT, IF YOU
WILL LOOK, THE RECORD WILL SHOW
THAT OUR CHINATOWN HAS BEEN A
MODEL OF CONTAINING AND
PRESENTING -- PREVENTING THE
VIRUS.
I’M CONFIDENT IN OUR FOLKS THERE
I THOUGHT IT WAS NECESSARY TO
OFFSET SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
THE PRESIDENT AND OTHERS WERE
SAYING ABOUT ASIAN-AMERICANS AND
MAKING THEM A TARGET.
OF TARGET OF VIOLENCE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> Chris: FORGIVE ME, DON’T
YOU THINK -- DON’T YOU THINK
THAT WHEN YOU’RE OUT WALKING
WITHOUT ANY MASKS.
I UNDERSTAND THIS IS FEBRUARY,
NOT APRIL, WHEN THIS HAPPENED,
AND SAYING THAT THERE’S NO
THREAT, IT’S PERFECTLY SAFE
THERE, WEREN’T YOU ALSO ADDING
TO THIS PERCEPTION THAT THERE
WASN’T SUCH A THREAT GENERALLY?
>> Speaker Pelosi: NO, I WAS
SAYING THAT YOU SHOULD NOT
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
CHINESE-AMERICANS AS SEMINAR
ADMINISTRATION WERE DOING BY THE
WAY THEY WERE LABELING THEM.
AND AGAIN, I THINK YOU CHECK THE
RECORD YOU WILL SEE THAT
CHINATOWN HAS BEEN A MODEL IN
ALL OF THIS.
AND THAT’S WHAT WE’RE SAYING,
LOOK TO THEM FOR ANSWERS, DON’T
LOOK TO THEM TO PLACE BLAME.
>> Chris: AS YOU KNOW,
PROTESTS AGAINST THE
STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS ARE GROWING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
PEOPLE ARE TAKING TO THE
STREETS, PUSHING BACK AGAINST
SOME OF THE MORE STRINGENT
RESTRICTIONS IN SOME STATES.
CAN YOU UNDERSTAND WHY THEY’RE
DOING THAT?
>> Speaker Pelosi: NO, NOT
REALLY, BECAUSE WHAT WE HAVE TO
DO IS SHELTER IN PLACE, AND THAT
IS REALLY THE ANSWER.
TESTING, TRACING, TREATMENT,
SHELTER IN PLACE.
AND I DO THINK THAT IT’S
UNFORTUNATE, BUT YOU KNOW,
PEOPLE WILL DO WHAT THEY DO, BUT
THE FACT IS WE ARE ALL IMPATIENT
IMPATIENT, WE ARE ALL WORN OUT,
WHAT THEY’RE DOING IS REALLY
UNFORTUNATE, BECAUSE WHAT IS
GREAT THOUGH IS -- ARE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THAT
THE GOOD HEALTH OF THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
LOVED ONES IS WHAT IS IMPORTANT
AND THAT’S WHY YOU HAVE SEEN
SUCH AN OVERWHELMING COMMITMENT
TO SHELTER IN PLACE AND
DISTANCING -- PEOPLE DISTANCING.
BECAUSE REALLY USE THE KEY TO
HOW WE WILL OPEN UP OUR ECONOMY.
THE HEALTH IS THE KEY TO OPENING
UP THE ECONOMY.
UNFORTUNATELY, WHAT YOU SEE
THERE IS WHATEVER PEOPLE THINK
THEY SHOULD SAY BUT THE FACT IS
THIS HAS TO BE SCIENCE-BASED,
EVIDENCE-BASED, DATA-BASED AND
THE SCIENCE AND THE EVIDENCE IN
THE DATA SAYS SHELTER IN PLACE.
TESTING.
CONTACT TRACING.
TREATMENT.
QUARANTINE IS THE ANSWER TO
OPENING UP OUR ECONOMY SOONER.
AND I THINK, BY THE WAY -- BY
THE WAY SO I JUST MAY ADD, I DO
THINK, FOCUSING ON THAT IS A
MAJOR DISTRACTION FROM TESTING,
TESTING, TESTING.
AND SO DOES THAT SERVE AS A
DISTRACTION?
YES, BUT THAT’S NOT WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE FOCUSING
ON GETTING OVER THIS SO THAT WE
CAN OPEN UP OUR ECONOMY.
THE SOONER THE BETTER.
AND I’M PROUD OF IT -- BY AND
LARGE THEY HAVE EMBRACED THAT.
>> Chris: A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS I WANT TO GET IN.
JUST THIS WEEK CALLED
PRESIDENT TRUMP A WEEK PERSON, A
POOR LEADER.
NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT HE GOES
AFTER YOU, SO THIS IS FULLY A
TWO-WAY STREET, BUT DO YOU THINK
THOSE KINDS OF PARTISAN ATTACKS
BY, IN THIS CASE, YOU ARE
CONSTRUCTIVE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
NATIONAL CRISIS?
>> Speaker Pelosi: OUT TELL
YOU WHY I CAME TO THAT.
I WAS VERY PRAYERFUL AND EASTER,
ONE OF THE FIRST DAYS I DIDN’T
HAVE TO BE WORKING EVERY MINUTE
AND I COULD REFLECT AND BE
PRAYERFUL, AND WHAT I DECIDED IT
WAS AS THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE
MANY MISTAKES.
LET’S HAVE AN AFTER ACTION
REVIEW OF THAT, BUT IF YOU
CONTINUE TO PUT FORTH PROPOSALS
THAT WERE NOT SCIENCE-BASED,
CONTINUALLY -- SAYING IT’S A
HOAX, IT’S MAGICAL GOING TO GO
AWAY.
PUT THAT ASIDE, BUT TO PROCEED
WITH POLICIES WHICH WERE NOT
SCIENCE-BASED, WHICH WERE NOT
EVIDENCE-BASED AND TO BLAME
OTHERS, BLAME ANYBODY, THE
GOVERNORS, ME, THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION, LEADERS -- LEADERS
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
SO I SAID HE’S A WEAK LEADER, HE
DOESN’T TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
HE PLACES BLAME ON OTHERS.
AND I MIGHT HAVE BEEN OKAY FROM
BEFORE, BUT WE CANNOT CONTINUE
DOWN A PATH THAT IS, AGAIN --
SCIENCE, SCIENCE, SCIENCE AND
THEN DATA ON HOW WE COULD GO
FORWARD.
>> Chris: FINALLY, AND I’VE
GOT ABOUT A MINUTE LEFT EAR,
SPEAKER PELOSI, WHEN THIS CRISIS
STARTED, YOU OPPOSED THE IDEA OF
CONGRESS VOTING REMOTELY,
SOMETHING HE HAS NEVER DONE
BEFORE, BUT IN THE LAST WEEK YOU
HAVE SAID THAT YOU COULD SUPPORT
REMOTE VOTING UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHAT WOULD YOU ACCEPT IN THAT
REGARD AND WHY THE CHANGE OF
MIND?
>> Speaker Pelosi: IT WASN’T A
CHANGE OF MIND, IT WAS A TEST
THAT ARE -- JIM McGOVERN,
CHAIRWOMAN OF THE HOUSE
ADMINISTRATION COMMITTEE TO SAY
WHAT ARE THE OPTIONS WE CAN GIVE
MEMBERS?
THIS IS WEEKS AGO.
WHAT ARE THE OPTIONS THAT WE CAN
GIVE MEMBERS CONSTITUTIONALLY,
SECURITYWISE AND TECHNOLOGICALLY
TECHNOLOGICALLY.
THEY CAME BACK THIS WEEK SAYING
PROXY VOTING IS PROBABLY
SOMETHING THAT PASSES MUSTER ON
THOSE SCORES IN TERMS OF JUST
FOR THIS PURPOSE, NOT FOR LIFE
IN GENERAL, BUT FOR THIS PURPOSE
AND SO THAT IS -- I’M TAKING A
RECOMMENDATION.
MY ATTITUDE WAS ALWAYS, IF IT’S
POSSIBLE, LET’S SEE WITH THE
OPTIONS ARE.
THIS IS WHAT THEY HAVE COME BACK
AND SET AS POSSIBLE.
AND IT HAS TO BE BIPARTISAN AND
OUR COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE AISLE, I THINK THERE IS
SOME OPENNESS TO IT, YOU HAVE TO
SLAM BUT WE WOULD WANT TO DO IT
IN THE CONGRESS, HOUSE-WIDE, NOT
JUST A DETERMINATION OF THE
DEMOCRATS THAT THAT’S THE WAY WE
WANT TO GO FORWARD.
WE WANT TO DO IT IN A BIPARTISAN
WAY.
AS WE GET DONE, ALL OF THIS.
AS THE INTERIM PACKAGE WILL BE
BIPARTISAN AND WE WANT TO KEEP
THE FAITH ON BOTH SIDES AND WITH
THE PUBLIC THAT THIS IS -- THIS
IS HOW WE HAVE TO COMPROMISE.
WE WANT TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS BUT
WE HAVE TO COMPROMISE AND GET
THE JOB DONE.
AND I MIGHT SAY, I’VE WORKED
WITH THE PUBLIC INSTITUTE
PASSING -- DECEMBER, PAST THE
U.S.-MEXICO-CANADA TRADE
AGREEMENT.
I WANT TO POINT THAT OUT.
>> Chris: SPEAKER PELOSI,
CREDIT WHERE CREDIT IS DUE,
CRITICISM OR CRITICISM IS DUE,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING AND
TALKING WITH US, PLEASE STAY
SAFE AND PLEASE COME BACK AND
TALK WITH US.
>> Speaker Pelosi: THANK YOU,
CREDIT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE